state house with the Republican majority
has voted to silence a democratic state
representative this time in Montana for
more than a week the state's first
transgender lawmaker was prevented from
speaking after a comment she made while
opposing a Republican bill Banning
gender affirming care for minors if you
vote Yes on this bill I hope the next
time there's an invocation when you bow
your heads in prayer you see the blood
on your hands
on Monday she raised a microphone to the
gallery in defiance as her supporters
chanted
[Applause]
on Wednesday she refused to apologize
the Republican majority unanimously
voted to ban Zephyr from the floor for
the rest of the legislative session
which ends in a few weeks